calls for diplomacy in Ukraine get the
cold shoulder when all they are saying
is give peace talks a chance Qatar and
World Cup 2022 the pr games are well
underway
and politics and tourism intersect
online the influencers on tour in Syria
hello I'm Richard gisbert and you're at
the listening post where we don't cover
the news we cover the way the news is
covered we're eight months into the war
in Ukraine and navigating through the
news output is not getting any easier
just a few weeks ago Western news
consumers were seeing reports of
Ukrainian counter-offensives pushing
Russian forces to the brink of defeat
what has followed has been the heaviest
Russian air campaign since the War Began
waves of missile strikes that have
crippled power plants water facilities
and hit hospitals if that initial
coverage was misleading other reporting
on the missiles that hit Poland has been
downright dangerous news outlets
parroting allegations that those
missiles were Russian led to some
politicians calling for NATO to get
involved it turns out the missiles were
Ukrainian and there are more and more
hints coming out of Washington that it's
time to bring the diplomats in to try to
end this war but for some U.S news
outlets like their Russian counterparts
diplomacy has somehow become a dirty
word
our starting point this week is the war
in Ukraine
consumers have good reason to be
confused by the reports coming out of
Ukraine lots of the country without
power often enough without water because
this past week Russia launched a series
of strikes targeting Ukraine's
infrastructure leaving an estimated 10
million people without power as winter
sets in what happened to that other
storyline that got so much play just a
few weeks ago her son was taken by
Russia early on in the war and is
recaptured by Ukraine is a major
strategic blow for the Kremlin The
Narrative that had Russian forces
retreating from places like Carson
allegedly in disarray moreover in this
week's attacks the Russian military
relied on the same weapons that Western
news audiences had been told Russia was
running out of the fog of War grows
thicker the truth harder to find we need
to be quite skeptical of the information
that we're being presented in all of
this
for example we've been told for months
months that the Russians are running out
of missiles and other Munitions a senior
U.S official is telling CNN
the Kremlin is struggling to maintain
its arsenal of high-tech weapons and
missiles but just last week we saw the
Russians launch the largest barrage of
missile attacks on Ukraine since the
start of the war so something doesn't
add up between what we're seeing on the
battlefield and the claims that we see
in a lot of the media coverage on this
the longer the school goes on and the
more desperate that the Russian military
gets the more they're going to resort to
increasingly destructive and
indiscriminate measures that will make
ordinary Ukrainian people suffer Wars go
back and forth there's there's
offensives counter-offensives
counter-counter offensives and given the
uncertainty around what exactly the
battlefield reality actually is I think
that points the need to try and find a
way to end this war and and find some
sort of Peace that's at least
sustainable even if it's not the ideal
situation for either party in this war
misinformation or substandard journalism
wherever the motivation lies does not
get get much more dangerous than what
came out of the Associated Press on
November 15th the day two missiles
landed on polish territory killing two
people the AP quoted a single Anonymous
U.S intelligence Source saying the
missiles were Russian by the time
officials from both the Polish
government and NATO made clear the
missiles were probably Ukrainian and had
veered off course ap's story had
traveled across other news outlets
Poland is a NATO country NATO has
Clauses in its Constitution that
stipulate when any of its member states
are attacked other NATO countries are
treaty-bound to come to its defense that
story ap's handling of it risked
something NATO countries insist they do
not want an escalation a widening of
this war the lesson is of course to be
very responsible and not to be driven by
confirmation bias
especially now at the heat of the our
conflict there was just one source
it
should have activated alarm bells in the
minds of the editors but that didn't
happen because everybody were expecting
Russia to do something like that we need
to be quite cautious about how the media
portray these kinds of incidents the
missile incident in Poland the Nordstrom
2 attack there's not a lot of direct
evidence about what has gone on there
and we we need to be careful that the
narratives that are being pushed by the
information Warriors don't precipitate
some sort of Confrontation between the
United States and Russia that could lead
to very dangerous escalation
AP acknowledged its failings the day
after the story came out issuing a
correction saying its anonymous source
was wrong five days after that it fired
the reporter responsible the escalation
narrative gets plenty of play on the
Russian Airwaves thanks to bellicose
voices like Vladimir solovyov of the
state-owned channel Rocio Juan
yes another
however more and more criticism is now
being directed at the Russian military
and its leaders for failures on the
battlefield
anchors and commentators still see a red
line they will not cross at the Kremlin
they do not dare criticize President
Putin so they've taken to complain about
the editorial restraints that Kremlin
has imposed on hemming them in
editorially on stories such as the
Russian Retreat from Carson
usually yeah
foreign
itself is not homogeneous it is common
in the in Russia analysis to
um to talk about the
competing uh towers of the Kremlin one
Tower fighting another and that is
reflected in the media
this fight of the Bulldogs and you can
see it on on Russian television channels
and also on telegram channels Russian
media don't know in which direction they
should go
confusing signals have been coming out
of Washington as well on November 9th
the US's top military officer General
Mark milley went against the White
House's official line saying that since
neither Russia nor Ukraine can hope to
achieve a military Victory the time had
come for diplomacy peace talks which
signals a significant term just last
month when 30 members of U.S Congress
Progressive Democrats quietly sent a
letter to President Biden calling for
negotiations the blowback much of it on
social media was so bad that the letter
was withdrawn that same day the group's
leader felt compelled to offer a
clarification every war ends with
diplomacy she said and this one will too
after a Ukrainian Victory nobody in
Washington wants to be labeled as soft
on Russia or somehow sympathetic toward
Putin and we saw that play out in the
media coverage the reaction was ironic
because very shortly after the letter
was retracted we learned that the
National Security advisor to President
Biden Jake Sullivan has in fact been
talking to the ukrainians about the
possibility of negotia Creations he's
been talking to senior advisors to
President Putin on the western
establishment and part of the media
community in the west
is so invested in this conflict they
dismissed diplomacy the president
[Music]
portrayed it and sponsored and ordered
by
Lottery
atrocities war crimes make him
unsuitable for any kind of a
conversation between they see it as
heresy but then if we are in in this
real situation where Russia is at least
for now is simply is stronger so it's
not looking like the Russian political
regime is going to collapse in in the
near future
um so why not uh talk about diplomacy it
also speaks to the role that the media
unfortunately has played throughout this
war which is to to egg on the Biden
Administration to be more aggressive
more escalatory uh to get deeper
involved in the conflict
I mean being
an intercept shoot down Russian incoming
is one thing but we know that ukrainians
want Advanced rocket systems at Ransom
Bissell a lot of the news coverage of
this war has taken on some of the worst
characteristics of Cold War reporting
and by the way how did the Cold War end
it ended through years if not Decades of
talks
the Cold War made us realize the
importance of talking to one's adversary
to one's enemy even especially if that
adversary is a hugely powerful country
that are sitting on thousands of nuclear
warheads
and some of that thinking has been lost
today I think
so much has been said and reported since
the World Cup opened in Qatar last week
Johanna Huss is in Doha with a look at
some of the international coverage
well Richard Doha put on a spectacular
opening ceremony featuring Hollywood
stars and a recitation of the Quran in
the first World Cup held here in the
Middle East however a narrative that has
remained in some International media is
the one about the suitability of Qatar
as a host country for the tournament
Britain's BBC for instance chose not to
broadcast the opening ceremony and
focused on rights instead discussing
labor and lgbtq issues FIFA sent out a
letter to all the teams didn't they say
and stick to football
and we'd love to we really would but
it's not possible is it Anna that led to
some pointing out that Qatar is being
exceptionalized compared to other World
Cups or Olympic Games these kind of
ramming politics into uh Sports and
using that kind of very high moralistic
tone is only reserved uh for other
countries it's never applied uh to
European countries nine months ago
Beijing hosted the Winter Olympics and
the BBC broadcast the opening ceremony
despite China being accused by multiple
countries of Acts of genocide in
xinjiang province in challenging some of
the questions raised about its rights
record and other matters Qatar has an
entire media Network all Jazeera on hand
a lot of people have perceptions of the
um or ideas about the Middle East do you
think the World Cup is a chance
to change that
absolutely the English and Arabic news
channels have devoted a lot of air time
to covering and even celebrating the
World Cup despite some of its
controversies
covering the first World Cup in the Arab
world has proven to be an interesting
assignment for TV journalists from
Israel as well from which TV you are
we're from Israel sorry Israeli
journalists are seeing firsthand that
despite the commitments of so-called
normalized relations across the region
many Arabs on the street continue to
protest the occupation of Palestine when
we're down three to go Qatar has
invested an estimated 250 billion
dollars into this tournament and along
with competing teams on the pitch there
are competing narratives of it
thanks Joe elsewhere in the Middle East
turkey Israel and Russia have all been
bombing various Targets in Syria a
reminder that peace there is still a
long way off it was 11 years ago during
the Arab Spring that Citizens First took
to the Syrian streets peaceful
demonstrations against the rule of
President Bashar al-assad they were met
with violence and brutality today
against long odds and With a Little Help
from some powerful friends Assad remains
in power and other governments are
slowly quietly re-establishing relations
in fact anyone browsing travel content
on social media would be forgiven for
thinking that normalization was already
a done deal foreign travel vloggers have
been visiting Damascus for years and
more recently they've even ventured into
territory that had been under opposition
control and was bombed accordingly by
Syrian and Russian forces the listening
posts Ahmed Madi now on the Curious
world of travel vlogging and what looks
like a Victory lap for the Assad regime
Friday was the bloodiest day of the
monthly protest in Syria for crimes
against humanity
for more than 10 years now the headlines
coming out of Syria have depicted
dictatorship this is the war Basha Assad
is waging on his own death nearly 12 000
children have been killed or injured and
destruction entire neighborhoods lie
destroyed leaving an apocalyptic scene
but in one corner of the internet you
can see a very different side to Syria I
love Syria and you will not believe how
amazing it is
good evening guys right now I'm in
Damascus thanks to some unlikely
visitors I first heard about travel
bloggers to Syria post-war uh in 2019.
good morning guys and welcome to
Damascus Syria I didn't know what to
expect from Damascus really but this
this wasn't really it like this it feels
like any other
nice touristy City it was amazing to see
Damascus again that's where my mom lived
for quite some time and as a Syrian I
got very emotional
seeing that footage and seeing
her eating the ice cream and they give
it to her for free but mostly I remember
being kind of shocked that they were
doing that already
stem the travel loggers were already
heading to Syria as a travel destination
we are in Japan guys another beautiful
sunny day in Barbados travel vlogging is
a huge online industry and to stand out
many vloggers have been visiting
so-called alternative travel
destinations
the kind more often seen in the
headlines than the travel brochures
in Libya unbelievable it's a winning
formula and it's generated millions of
views and dollars for both the content
creators and the social media companies
I was just so hyped and all
about Syria
but in a place like Syria is this
content cut in Corners with the truth
just to please the algorithms you know
when there's a war
it's not raining bombs on every single
inch of Syria people are still living
there my family is still there they
still you know go to work every day but
this very simplistic view of life in
Syria lacks Nuance of how life actually
is inside a war these streets that I saw
in the videos are are real but they're
very touristy Sierra is very big and
it's not one one neighborhood or or one
very instagramable Street
really just stopped for a photo of that
look at that we asked the Syrian tourism
Ministry whether foreign travel
influencers were being invited into the
country for PR purposes they didn't
respond what we do know is that every
tourist visiting Syria travel vloggers
included is legally required to be
accompanied at all times by a
government-approved guide what
journalists would call a Handler so
while vloggers are exploring the markets
of Damascus
so good roaming the ruins of Aleppo
foreign
he's a travel vlogger who just returned
from Syria a few weeks ago of course I
had to get a guide and you cannot just
wander around yourself as a tourist with
a touristic Visa in Surya I'm here with
my guide Mary so what the guides do
after you leave the country they're
reporting it to the government where
have you been and what you have done in
the country this is the real nightlife
of Syria as of now check this out I was
there during the Christmas time people
were having fun in the cafes having
shisha so this is one of the videos I
shared as well but I also shared other
parts of it the leftovers from the Civil
War do you want to see what Civil War
brings to the country right now I'm in
Syria in the biggest city called homes
and all around me is just Eastern
buildings I think people specifically
syrians had very mixed feelings about my
content they were thinking that I am
sold out and I am it's a propaganda for
the government and I'm actually paid to
be in Surya and make this content which
is absolutely not true story is not only
about Civil War and depressing headlines
hey the food fun fact on Christmas Day
the same day you posted that regime
sponsored propaganda six opposition
Fighters were murdered in Northern Syria
one of the reasons why I made that Tick
Tock about davood is he specifically
made a video of some destroyed buildings
and his messaging was see what war gets
you it gets you nothing as a result this
is what we have left which to me was
very heart-wrenching there are results
of the war with the regime every travel
vlogger I'm aware of says well I'm not
political and but how can you show the
destruction of a political war and still
be a political when you go into a war
zone and say it's a political it's only
documentation and you're showing only
one side then if you're documenting you
should actually do more research and
more work and go to places where you
know you don't have a fixer from
the side of the regime showing you
around this is a very political space
you're standing in that is under regime
control and the regime is showing you
what they want the world to know
part of the problem is that journalists
are not being allowed in
except for media from countries the
regime considers friendly like Russia
and Iran states that have backed
president bashad al-assad a few foreign
reporters have been able to visit
government Health Syria in recent years
that's left the vloggers and other more
controversial figures to fill the
information Gap
blurring the lines between content
creator and journalist there are
women I'm not a journalist I'm just a
simple content creator and I feel like
people right now trust individuals and
the content creators more than the news
what I wanted to do is just show a
little bit different side and more
authentic side of Surya Surya will
become and as a very important
destination for the region and the for
the touristic destination as well and I
do feel like the content I share helps
it a little bit
despite the ongoing fighting
millions of syrians displaced on the
fact that around a third of the country
remains Beyond his control Assad is
ready to reintroduce himself to the
world
States that had once denounced his rule
are now resuming diplomatic ties and
along with it lucrative energy and trade
deals
for the global news audience however
it's a much harder sell and that's why
the regime needs all the help it can get
when you have 10 years of conflict
afterwards comes you know the writing
History part the normalization with the
World Part these vloggers are a very
small part of this plan I personally
don't think that
tourism right now in Syria is ethical it
is only aiding the
bigger message that the regime wants
to come across which is that Syria is
safe Syria is not safe especially not
for syrians who want to return every
Syrian wants
the world to hear and to see Syria as
they know it as this beautiful
historical magical place and in that
sense who can blame the travel vloggers
for willing to tell that story but this
tourism without journalism
is mostly harmful
I want the story of Syria to be told
but I want the whole story told
and finally the Pakistani film Joyland
and the continuing drama around it
two months ago Joyland was submitted as
Pakistan's official entry for the
Academy Awards then after complaints
from the leader of a religious party it
was banned in Pakistan then it was
cleared and allowed back into Cinemas
but only after certain scenes had been
cut Joyland is about A Love Affair
between a man and a transgender woman it
is not the first film to get this kind
of treatment from the country's sensors
that point has been made on social media
where pakistanis have been posting lists
of other films that have been either
banned or censored films that the
authorities in Islamabad are no fans of
we'll see you next time here at the
listening Coast
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]